they may take a minute or two yeah we're
live right now on Twitch or are we it's
loading no it's got a load that see you
guys you guys watch the twitch channel
you guys see what's going on it's always
a mystery to me when you guys say what's
happening yeah Chad I normally don't but
like I like to jump on now is it I've
like isn't this broadcasting on Twitch I
mean it went live let's see what the
chat says yeah they can see it yes see
you guys you guys watch them on YouTube
wow so we're live on YouTube and
simulcast
or my youtube my twitch is like frozen
like it's not doing anything is it
that's fine you're good do we unlock
some sort of achievement for
simulcasting both on Twitch and I feel
we should at least get a cookie yeah wow
that's amazing all right I wonder if
anybody's gonna show up - well this is
still time will come into coffee week
with you at home the second week we pull
this very special episode of comics and
coffee on twitch and YouTube little
multicast that's a good name
yes I like that Leeloo Dallas multicast
alright I don't even know if anybody's
not gonna show up on on youtube I don't
know
well it shouldn't tell your subscribers
which would be amazing yeah I would
think so
but I'm a little bit will or not like if
anybody what's your love it's the
Hypertime cast taking place in the many
rivers and tributaries I've no really
tried like the whole YouTube like the
whole YouTube just direct streaming yeah
like I've been really given that a
chance so yeah it's weird
it has 78 likes and one person watching
it that one person was me
yeah that's not true that one person is
so happy just for that person when I
when the first time I streamed on
YouTube when I was watching a comic I
had oral explain yeah that was Marvel
explain
it was literally like five people who
are watching this is the trust me I know
exactly I feel like anytime you have
like whatever do a live thing and this
more than like a person or two like it
used to be when I used to do ice to play
with like with YouTube a lot we would
just go live and his try things before
we even did comics I was like let's just
let's just go live and like we'd have
like three people in the chat oh my whoa
why are you watching this do better
things to do like a live stream know
where we're coming up hey when it's
gonna happen but it should be happening
soon you guys had an epic the last time
you hit a milestone like that six hours
or something yeah it was know when it is
before actually happens so that we don't
feel bad like when we're like four hours
in and someone's like I just found out
about the show my oh my guess we should
hang out I jumped in listen to hear my
name mentioned stanza yeah alright so so
what's going on guys
actually let me record this while we're
before we officially start Rob Hughes
smokescreen it was super effective yes
gob you gob uses smokescreen it's super
effective actually I don't know if I
need to read one more record anyway just
in case it's the kids YouTube freaks out
or something like that but um anyway
guys welcome to this week's episode of
the weekly pool I guess kind of it's me
and a sow and it's joel from come
forecast and we're trying out multiply
screaming like multiply casting where
it's less yeah on twitch and on youtube
and we thought it'd be kind of a cool
idea and it is it's a really really cool
idea I think and so um we don't really
have topics per se we're just kind of
going over the comments that we've been
reading I guess and this is gonna be a
relatively short one this was only gonna
be about an hour or so because I think
the sound needs to take off to record
his shows today and I know that the
Joel's got stuff to work on and I need
to work on the script for the Phoenix
Ford or I guess the Phoenix saga and
that kind of stuff from Marvel and so
yeah like we're really kind of a kind of
I guess what's the phrase I shoot from
the head she
we're live this week so okay so what
somebody reading right now at the moment
at least you enjoy anyway everything cuz
that's kind of what our jobs entail is
you know I actually did a blood sweat
counts which is the show where we talk
about what we read last night and I've
talked about and I've already forgotten
what I read so I'm now going to go to
the platelets that actually see what I
read this week nice okay well I mean I'm
we were reading all the friggin Civil
War titles and I'm really digging the
hell out of out of 1872 yeah that's a
fun one isn't that good it is so good
Duggan is such an underrated talent man
and the fact that he gave you comedy and
he can do stuff like that yeah I really
think that one yeah it's really really
cool like he's he is excellent we should
get him on at some point cuz I bet he's
friggin fascinating that's one of those
times where I'm like man I actually
really liked it if this one stuck around
after see yeah I would like to read the
Wild West Marvel Adventures
but then again ask Jonah haslums about
you know the success of Western comic
while this yeah x-men like I read those
Cummings briefly like when the movie
came out [ __ ] dude yeah
Palme IATI justin gray man they had some
amazing runs all that both in the old 52
and in the new 52 they were rockin Jonah
Hex and they actually wrote him an
ending he's one of the few characters
who actually got like a decent ending
what is canceled yeah yeah um kind of a
fun fact when I was going through and
reading yeah what was it um oh when I
was going through my doing my video on
the flash and I was going through the
history of Wally West one thing that
kind of amazed it was I didn't realize I
think it was Mark Waid wrote like a ton
of stuff oh yeah
like Mark Waid was like the Chris
Claremont of the flash series now yeah I
was like oh my god he wrote for so long
and introduced so much something it was
really really cool but see here's a
funny thing going through Wally West
history like I didn't I never really
thought about it until
sat down and and sort of like looking at
the history of Wally West versus the
history of like a Barry Allen stuff like
that way like there was no Barry Allen
from laying the crisis on Infinite
Earths going forward he appears oh yeah
handful of times when I picked up comics
for the first time it was all Wally all
the time mess dude for like 27 years it
was worthless and so that's why I ever
understood like when I did that video
and I was sitting here thinking about it
because I was then I tried this into the
end of the video I was you know I mean
it you know my idea is to give people a
facts not necessary to give you know to
give opinions but all right you know my
thought was why is Wally West not the
flash in this new story that's what a
lot of people have been asking and you
know what a lot of people would argue
even the people who really love the
flash TV show know he's kinda more Wally
than he is very honestly and they've
even given him now one of Wally's old
girlfriends and they're bringing in zoom
for season two who was the reverse-flash
of Wally not Barry
yeah that's me well like everything I
think as far as I'm concerned I feel
like Wally's had more time to grow and
become like his own flash and he had he
had Justice League enniaa Justice League
which was awesome best for me but like
because Barry they kicked it in 86 and
and it was Wally from there till what
2011 or no I'm sorry know what whatever
rebirth was rebirth so was probably
2008-2009 literally have rebirth over on
my shelf I should go but he's had like a
really really like not even not even the
question of like has Wally been around
longer it's more about like when stories
started to become more complex and
interesting and when they really started
like delving into character that's when
Wally was the flash so obviously like
Wally got a significant amount more
development yeah so as a result I think
there's like there's a lot of ground
being laid by everybody especially like
Wade who's you know who excels at
character work and John's who had the
character for a long time do I actually
have a bunch of this was a little train
sitting around it's true I always
assumed that that John's had it out for
Wally that like that
is always like just can't wait taking a
berry back in the picture
and he wrote him for a very long time
too before he did time so I think it's
more just like that the John's I mean
like it could be he was playing the long
game I kind of hoped I think he was I
think he was like and then later yeah
does he even like threw him into like
Infinite Crisis or yeah if in a crisis
like by art like Barry shows up for a
page or two and then go to the Speed
Force whereas I got him
okay run and then you never see him
again yeah I mean you got to think of a
creator who spent so much time bringing
his favorite characters back to life
where he's like oh I'll bring flash back
and also bring Hal back and all the
other old Green Lantern stuff back and
I'll make it like the biggest bestest
book for like years and I'll continue to
do it in the new 52 yeah I mean I can't
argue with the with his success and his
effectiveness I you know I was not wowed
by Justice League vol 1 with a new 52
but you know I didn't jump into that
until after forever evil yeah I knew I
knew but like which I hear is great and
I've got to read it at some point but
like it's enjoyable we uh yeah I mean
it's David Finch and like David Finch
Isambard tastes but I really I really
really like dark side war where that's
going
it's fun it's good they've really they
have up their auntie I think bringing
the multiverse back really held them and
actually sell the last night was on the
show I want to talk to you about this
with Dark Side where were you tagged out
so I couldn't finish this one what's the
over/under right now on the horrible
secret of Wonder Woman that they're
going to reveal do you think it's gonna
be oh hey you're actually the daughter
daughter yeah oh hey the baby's got
switched at birth turns out Grails the
good woman you're the bad do they need
to do something magazine right now man
like I was I was going through and I'm
going like I'm doing all the new 52
characters like I'm getting Batman up
until the point where we get to Batman
in game and then I'm switching over and
doing like like cuz I'm gonna do the
characters like like required reading
basically because like Superman like
it's like Superman and then I'm gonna
jump to the pre lewd to Superman truth
you know Jeff jobs run and the music man
truth because you don't need to read
anything else but he's not to read you
know to understand truth anyway
and Wonder Woman like I was going
through and I was like in her story arcs
and I was like I don't care anything
about her story welcome to me four years
ago Rob what's happening yeah I don't
care about her nothing about what's
going on with Wonder Woman and like I
was looking at the sales and I'm not the
only one who doesn't care about Wonder
Woman because well apparently from what
I understand again I don't review the
book regularly Matt doesn't he says the
book is actually taking a major hit
since Dark Side war has started cuz he
feels that the finches are kind of
spinning their wheels right now they're
afraid to do anything new because of
what might very well be revealed about
her in Dark Side war so they're kind of
like this story that's what I'll give
Nancy to me you know here's here's I
guess DC doesn't do this but here's what
makes sense to me all right Darkseid
Wars is obviously a great big huge thing
and this is why I don't like a DC saying
hey what goes on in one comic doesn't
necessarily influence the other
yeah it doesn't you know I don't I don't
like that you know if they're gonna do
something like Dark Star Wars you know
and they're gonna say hey guys we're
gonna have this great big huge event
we're gonna have the dark side Wars the
anti-monitor is coming back whole nine
yards like it's gonna be this great big
huge thing is probably gonna be another
crisis you know and it's gonna be it's
gonna be nuts
well they say they're damaged another
crisis cause another crisis will destroy
the universe they made a point of saying
that with Metro it's the anti-monitor
he's literally involved in every single
crisis the energy expended by the
anti-monitor will like you will you even
get like you like even after Infinite
Crisis like nothing really like they
covered the multiverse but like oh also
some history change to like a little bit
you know like like I gave up on how they
view their universe and I just don't
like the Skinner II like the Telus guy
the telescope was like I can I can make
things back then you know I can fix
things the only way I can do that though
is if you go back and read Khan crisis
on Infinite Earths
and I was like oh my god so Christ
nothing matter and that's that's why I
like when I made that video I was like I
was trying to phrase that as best I
could in that video like like I'm
basically what I'm telling people here
is DC's had a series of crises and they
reboot of the universe and there's been
changes and now none of that matters
anymore and it's just like even get to
see what happens
yeah well assumedly in that Superman
book we might get to see what happens
cuz again I get just followed you get we
get to follow your dad Superman the
Superman everybody likes ya now gets to
be with Lois and his baby and they're
gonna be in a whole other universe and
we're yet to follow them I will say that
I'm excited to see what see how that
meet Jim I really love like the meant
like the Superman Man is feel time for
convergence was to me the best one of
the best long swings but yeah
nonetheless you know I'm going through
and I'm sitting here thinking you know
if they're gonna do something like that
like there's you you the writers have to
like there has to be a citizen somebody
has to make it has to send out something
there has to be an editorial mandate
that says we are not doing continuity
they can't walk this two line and say
what we're kind of doing continuity but
we're kind of not because then you run
into that problem well you have Wonder
Woman books where you're like
something's gonna be revealed about her
that's gonna change her character
forever and so the writers are the
Wonder Woman books are kind of like well
I mean do we keep going forward I mean
what do we do if the saner is like
there's no continuity what happens when
the Wonder Woman books does not is not
influenced and in no way has any bearing
on what happens in the Justice League
then that needs to be the case and they
need to have giant purple letters when
you go and buy the comic or when you
open up the first page says what happens
in this book is not affected by anything
that goes on in the Justice League
Justice League it's totally isolated
read them separately or something so
that fans know and here's the reason why
because if someone that's never read a
comic book you know some some 14-year
old girl
that's like you know what I really think
that like women should have strong
representation economies and I should
you know I'm gonna go read Wonder Woman
to see if that's what's happening and
then they go buy a Wonder Woman comic
and they say well I like this I'm gonna
buy the Justice League and then they're
gonna freak out because if in her solo
series you know she's fighting crime you
know and she's banging that one guy you
know
whatever do that works for the
government or whatever it is you know
when like Steve Trevor even still around
characters he only makes sense in a
world war two context and I know because
he's actually pretty good in bombshell
yeah great title yes but I know right if
they pass that off and they say well you
know I mean she's got her own thing
around and then darkside Wars like well
you're the daughter of Darkseid then
then fans are gonna be like what in the
heck is going on here and so well
they're gonna say like why like who
cares yeah what a matter was like at the
end of the day it doesn't matter because
Wonder Woman will do what one woman does
or doesn't do whether she's clay or
whether she's a god or whether she's a
clay a god or an answer or or a new God
like no one's gonna give it the there's
some pathos there and I'm sure like
maybe Batman will be like oh well the
daughter Darkseid I can't trust me right
now yeah well you know she snapped the
neck of uh you know Maxwell or max
Maxwell Lord so and he was mr.
dependable reasons for that for the
Justice League to have a problem with it
with Wonder Woman that's not new that's
not interesting
did you know Maxwell Lord is back now
actually in grace and they mentioned him
and checkmate are back now oh good yeah
yeah that's good you know it's funny I
was just reading an article from comic
book resources they were talking to I
remember who it was but one of the like
one of the the the writer in question
was self-proclaimed as one of the most
like reviled Batman writers of all time
and it sounds more like his ego than
anyone giving a [ __ ] but the guy is
responsible for kind of like writing a
bunch of stories post-crisis by Jason
Todd mm-hm and he talked about how he
loved writing for bet he loved the idea
of writing for Batman he couldn't wait
to write about Batman and when he sat
down he was like okay where's the Batman
Bible that I needed to use the order to
write they were like oh there isn't one
he was okay well so Bruce Wayne Manor
where is that in in relation to Gotham
City
who cares and he's like you don't you
don't have any control over or any like
plan for one of your most popular and
money-making characters of all time like
theirs and they don't care either wasn't
even like nah we never really got around
to it
it was kind of like ya know we don't
just do whatever you want whatever like
even a-19 like 87 they didn't give a
crap and as though I feel like you know
I don't think the winds have changed
that much over TC since then and when
cell says a Bible he means like when you
write for a show or a movie usually you
have a production Bible which is like
these are the rules of the universe
these are the things that cannot be
contradicted or else you're gonna have a
problem yeah it is funny to think comics
are so much a more fluid art form that
they don't have those things yeah I mean
like I remember that they used to I
remember that like you know they they
didn't have a Bible let me put it this
way they had like a whiteboard then they
had their plot lines for for the bit for
the for the main guys like for Superman
for Batman for spider-man like they had
different like whiteboards for like you
know web of spectacular Peter Parker you
know the like it all these different
titles and then the plot lines and
they're like okay and this is this is
the ongoing story and here's where your
story will cross over or be affected by
this and blah blah so they had some like
not just DC but the you know the big to
have had some kind of structure but I
don't think they've ever had like a
thing where they're like like I mean
proofing there's proof in dance lots
Twitter if you ever watch if you ever
follow Dan slide oh yeah it's an
excellent Twitter feed yeah it's a great
Twitter feed I couldn't follow him after
a while because he doesn't know what
Twitter swore you know I have a point
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweets we I'm
like okay man I got like 200 or to look
like a real writer yeah but were like
yeah well actually he's a real big
proponent of twit longer where you just
click it yeah yeah diet Robert wrote but
like he will just take the Twitter be
like how many people are responding name
all the people who were responsible who
Peter Parker is responsible for their
death because I think I have a number
but I don't know because there's no
Bible because no there's no thing that
says these the people the Peter Parker's
kill
it's kind of cool that he engages the
fans it's like look you guys are gonna
be people who are mad at me if I get
this wrong so just tell me now well yeah
and he's like I mean you guys have-have
thanklessly and fine and and and you
know for no restitution devoted your
lives research knowing this I mean like
there actually is by the way I propose
that one thread there is a website
devoted to the amount of people that
Peter Parker is directly or indirectly
responsible for killing and it's a lot
higher than to iPad well here's here's
kind of the kicker for me like this that
was one thing that always sort of amazed
me was like I mean I have my go to
sources that that I consider to be
extremely reliable sources you know for
information me aside from the source
material in comics you know if I'm
looking to verify where to find
something that maybe in a comic I've got
my own sources for that and so I'll you
know go and grab those sources and look
through them to comb through them that
kind of stuff you know and then
eventually you know locate the comic
read it and verify that information but
yeah it's the fact that the things are
so chaotic that it's it's almost that's
that's well that's one of the most
difficult things about like making
videos you know like explaining like
I'll be doing a video about the Shiar
empire as part of the lead-up to comics
or I just saw it to the to the Phoenix
saga and the problem is almost
everything comes after but even a lot of
stuff this featured in there it's super
obscure like when I did the Phoenix
force video but here's the history the
chronological history of the Phoenix
force you know as historical as it can
get that video was so difficult to make
because literally the history of the
Phoenix force is scattered everywhere
and there's no one definitive thing it's
not like a book there's somebody never
released a book that said ahead like
here's everything you want to know about
the Phoenix saga yeah they did that yeah
they do that if they said like like they
made a book called like Marvel Comics
the definitive Phoenix force yeah it was
just everything about the Phoenix force
every comic book appearance everything
you know and all I kind it wouldn't be
like it's not like it's gonna be a
700-page thing I use big volumes and
you're done yeah make it like Chris
Claremont run make it and then do I just
put it in after they like everything
that comes after that because the
problem was like the white hot room
because if you read like Claremont's
arrow the white-hot room was just like
this giant castle in the middle of dying
we're arguing about this with vows last
week I remember it's the white outer
room is a giant castle in the middle of
the m'kraan crystal surrounded by space
but if you go when you read the Phoenix
or the Phoenix in song it's just a giant
room if you can read something from the
Fantastic Four it's it's like this
universe looking thing it's everybody
depicts at different ways and that's the
problem is there's no universal standard
there's no point at which every writer
or every artist can go to the singular
location and say okay this is how it's
supposed to be depicted so I will depict
it that way and so every mind of my hot
room right now yeah so everybody
different ways everybody looks at it in
different you know different forms in
front and it's and it's weird because
people add to it as time goes on which I
understand but the reason people add to
it we're looking will change it is
because there's no definition for it
there's no one absolutely thing I mean
at this point you know with with Marvel
rebooting you know their whole
multiverse now's the time to do that you
know to say like here's how these like
whatever it isn't we're gonna keep this
is the Bible for that stuff this is how
all that stuff exists like you know
they're not rebooting their characters
and they might but the problem is that
right now like Miles Morales and the
Secret Wars event and it has all the
Ultimate Universe continuity he's still
there that's still a part of his
character all that's still you know
still real and and I would hope I would
really really hope that model is gonna
do this that when Secret Wars is over
that they're gonna be like continuity
reboot everything starts at zero and
then just go from there like make Miles
Morales part of like the main the new
and yeah just like new 52 their whole
thing and just the way they're going
with this like my universe is dead no my
friends are gone it's like just it's
just he waving at us treat him like he
was always there yeah yeah in this room
like he's always been there or whatever
yeah whatever the case may be yes I mean
like I I'm a suit I'm honestly like
that's that's probably what they'll do
yeah because I've been assuming just
naturally that when it all ends
everyone's gonna go who those Secret
Wars were crazy let's get back to
stopping the Wrecking Crew from robbing
the first national here's a question
will old man Logan always have been old
in this thing will they just be like oh
man remember how old Logan is old all
the time man old man Logan will probably
be the guy who remembers everything
yeah he lives
the issue is he's going on a nice little
walking tour now of the entire Secret
Wars universe from legend apocalypse to
the ultimate universe to the zombie
world and everything yes funding his
actual book it's a really yeah like
that's the issue with Secret Wars
because with with like with flashpoint
it was it was self-contained it was easy
DC came along and said what like I think
South Sound said it best I'll never
forget this sounds best
he said the DC editorial were sitting
around they were like here's a story
like flash goes school looking thing we
can make action figures out of and then
one and then and then he fixes it and
then he goes back and everything's fine
yeah and somebody said what if he didn't
yeah what if everyone was young and had
stupid collars yeah and so that's it
like that it was it was say what you
want about flashpoint at least it was
done well they were like okay flashpoint
he goes back in time you know and
because of that like he's these screws
with the Speed Force he screws like he
basically screws up time and so now
everything's like computer drifter is
hanging out with the Justice hey guys I
was oh I love how they buried grifter
and basically everyone short of
Midnighter cuz he's kind of like Val
what's like look you wild store heroes
you stand in the friggin corner okay we
tried with you very hard at all I mean I
don't
they gave Gail Samoan like the Gen 13
book but they didn't give a crap just
been like they should call whatever top
cow's calling themselves now yeah I just
be like please do something with this
they also didn't care about milestone
and they didn't care about Blue Beetle
either her beetle oh I know and I'm a
Rhea's yeah oh I always like Ted Kord
but I I appreciate hi Mayes attempted a
movie I mean like he's he's everywhere
like that version the raise character
he's like he's in no pop culture that
the alias absolutely and you know what
the saddest thing about Blue Beetle was
he was getting such a massive push on TV
with Young Justice just as they were
canceling his book they're like oh
people love ya Jaime we're gonna cancel
your book now yeah but your books over
yes YouTube made a really good color he
said a Marvel Comics similarly that's
who we need we just stuff like we need a
Lord of the Rings similarly and applied
to Marvel apply to like how many books
in general like and and that's that's
why I say like that's why I love Secret
Wars but I hate Secret Wars
I love Secret Wars because it's its new
like it's it's something totally
different we've never seen I like it
just because it's a break away from
everything we've seen so far
because unexpected yeah like everything
that Marvel has done up to this point
it's just like well let's take our most
popular groups and make them fight and
that's it which is totally what I
thought Secret Wars was gonna be when
they say like oh so we're just gonna get
up everyone on a plane and we're gonna
fight for the future there were oh no
it's a crazy alternate reality game of
Thrones everyone is gonna cells but not
themselves and an arc okay that's what
I'm thinking that's the and plus is
written by Hickman and here's here's why
I see Hickman man Hickman if you ever
happen to see this like like you're my
homeboy I love your stories I'll love
them to the hang out and I'll swear by
every single story you like but Hickman
has a habit of saying like here's the
story and the story's going along
story's coming along left field
BAM everything changes and it's like
really apparently so much to the point
that he needs an extra issue now to
finish secret war not only not only an
extra issue an extra dish you in the in
addition to like the double size issues
yeah that are coming out they're putting
in double books and they're getting
another double book so we've got we've
got 3:40 issue books coming out plus
another one and so my thought here's
that here's my here's my thought here's
like wishful thinking
all right on the end of Secret Wars I
have two ideas on what's happening the
first is that it's all happening in the
white-hot room like inside the m'kraan
Chris
the one above all is still there like
the super overseer of everything in
existence is so there beyonders never
killed him because they were there was
never an instance in a history of
Marvel's continuity there's never been
an instance
well the Bourne above all ever became
involved in the original beyonder or any
of the other beyonders so they've never
cross paths and so like like you're
talking about like the the creator of
all things
and the problem is Marvel's never
established how the beyonders relate to
everything else
Leia's is the beyond like
he invented him they'd he invented the
beyonders like a year ago well no I mean
no they've been around along yeah
they've been around a long video there
has been around know the beyonders have
been around for a long time the not not
the way in which Hickman has portrayed
no no before looking like the young
beyond her being like it yeah yeah his
white suit yeah
the jheri-curl beyond her was like a
child yeah like a baby under back Ann's
back in the day not gonna see this is
why I loved the old school stuff so much
back in the day you have Secret Wars
number one be honor shows that Secret
Wars number to be honor comes to earth
kind of Secret Wars number three Doctor
Doom and the Fantastic Four travel into
the negative zone they encountered like
cubic and that's what that's what they
did with molecule man and the Beyonder
they made him into a cosmic cube yeah
what happened during that is they one of
the people explain what cosmic cubes are
how they work and they reference the
beyonders which were these beings that
were and some other dimension or
something like that and they never cross
over an Artem and that's it you got a
one page explanation that's all we got
about to be honest we didn't know didn't
know anything that's why I said was a
huge deal when Hickman came along and
hank pym shows up and he's like to be
otters are here and i was like holy cow
like this because because Hickman was
drawing on some super obscure stuff to
make this happen and so yeah there be
honors as they're depicted we never knew
what they look like like we never knew
what they look like what form they took
what they were capable of yeah we just
knew they were some super powerful
beings a problem that Marvel has those
Marvel business Marvel's never answer
the question how did the universe of the
dimension of the honors exist was a part
of the all-encompassing Marvel Universe
was it a universe away from the yeah
that's they never answer that question
so and they don't care and so you know I
doubt we'll see anything about the one
above all but my thought is even if they
did something will happen where like the
powers of the honors will be dispersed
or something like that you know but in
any event it's all going to probably
culminate and of course Doctor Doom
being destroyed but someone and I think
it's gonna be Franklin Richards
someone's gonna come along bring all
that in that Franklin Richard Franklin
Richards man somebody's gonna come along
and and reset it all here's why I say
that because future foundation was all
about Franklin Richards like Hickman's
run of the Fantastic Four was
about Franklin Richards like that was a
culmination of the story Franklin
Richards
you know and he has basically been
telling one long story worm is fantastic
for run yeah even though I think the
final battle is gonna be Reed Richards
and dr. doom and Eggman is gonna be like
no this is the story I've been writing
this whole time I mean it would be cool
if we had like a Phoenix Phoenix force
power to Reed Richards any kind of cool
to see yeah yeah I feel like they'll
probably just be cleaning house as far
as like everyone goes they might just
because it's kind of steeped in Marvel
continuity Marvel like cosmic a little
bit not really they might just be like
yeah and Franklin Richards explodes to
rebuild the universe and valaria goes
with them and becomes like eternity and
that way we have between spaces right
and that and that way we can have Reed
and Sue be young and they and they're
not bad parents so that we can like have
that all over again because you know if
they're gonna take that opportunity to
like reboot everything or kind of like
soft reboot everything and make
everybody young and a hit and and hip
and interesting I mean the you know why
not get rid of them like what I get rid
of like the the the cosmic you know
corrector that known as Franklin's the
st. elsewhere character like Tommy
Westfall exactly so Tommy Westfall of
the Marvel unit
if anyone has a has a Bible or or a plan
its Marvel now and I don't mean like
with an exclamation point I mean like
presently I think that all-new
all-different marvel does have like at
least maybe not like a book but maybe
like a poster with a bunch of bullets on
it that say things like at least a
year's worth of ideas well and and
things like you can't have like here's
what we have here's who's in charge this
is the universe like you know maybe with
a wiped clean the cosmic slate and like
there is no more like ego and there is
no more you know the like the hierarchy
they got rid of it all and they're like
no there's God maybe and the alternate
realities and dimensions and that's it
I do feel like they probably have some
kind of plan as opposed to now um
nothing
in thinking about it though like it or
not that would be that would be the
smart call because I thought interview
once where Hickman said that he always
starts from the from the ending of the
story and worse his way forward and so
my father always especially while he's
writing it or well it's coming out
that's my thought is the best way to do
that would like here's here's what I
think would be cool is if Hickman
revealed that these aren't in fact those
universes that like like Days of Future
past or like like what happened was when
dr. doom was going through all those
realities and killing all those versions
of molecule man that when he gained the
powers of the beyonders all he did was
like recollect those universes and make
them into a singular location so like
those are those are what he's remember
those universes being but aren't
actually those universes but regardless
like I mean the smart move would to be
would be to simply say okay fine like
take the powers the beyonders like wipe
everything out the power gets dispersed
BAM the multiverse is worn and like the
multiverse is born of the power of the
beyonders yeah and that's where
everything comes from so now you got the
power that beyonders out of the way so
you don't have to worry about that
exactly no one can yeah like we've done
that like you'll never see another story
or Doctor Doom or some other or Thanos
goes to try and do the same thing dude
in like that so that's that's going like
that powers it's usually energy of that
to restart the universe so in fact
you're doing like a Big Bang and then
you're gonna do like more or less a time
jump of a trillion years yeah to where
Marvel had a continuity and here it's
not a trillion years it's only gonna be
eight months because it's a callback to
the in eight months
everything zoom well now it's months
later like this which is kind of a smart
idea to be like hey we could spend a
bunch of time building up but let's jump
e in media res and show like it's a
really good idea because it allows them
to also be like yeah we could retcon
that like we could all we've always read
comics that was a cool theme because
then what they did is they turned around
and said like do you want to know what
happens during that eight months and
fans were like yeah and they're like go
read that character solo serious
yeah already publishing please yeah like
that's what we know let's say speaking
of that threat they're still coming out
with last days of books magneto came out
this week and ant-man came out ant-man
was special because he didn't get like
ant-man issue 6 comma last days of this
was last days of ant-man number one he
got a special one and I gotta say the
ant-man last days of special was amazing
like it was an excellent single issue it
may be one of the best single issue
stories I've read in a very long time
they give him a hell of a send-off in
this final issue and it is just a gut
punch Nick Spencer is the man man oh
yeah that's not as waiting this for like
a bunch of those so that's that's that's
why Marvel is really just kind of like a
like a pitfall right now it's because at
least for us anyway because right now
there's no stories to tell in Marvel
there's Secret Wars but like last days
hasn't finished and that's why to this
day I'll always curse Marvel for the
whole thing because the best decision
they could have made the smartest
decision was to say last days kill off
everybody and then start Secret Wars yes
and then going to Secret Wars and let's
take only some books are having last
days of it's like well dick well
daredevil gets to finish the way drunk
as daredevil has always made a lot of
money we don't want to miss writing it
he says he didn't want to do that yeah
somebody mentioned Silver Surfer I'm
actually dying to see what happens with
Silver Surfer because the last sighs the
last issue at least the last issue that
I read was Silver Surfer was that he was
he had like transition to like a pocket
dimension yeah we're here like eternity
was doom yeah he missed like he out he
out surfed the end of reality yeah dawn
greenwood from massachusetts that's what
i mean like like in the silver surfer
books is probably where some of that
some of that stuff will be explained
like gonna be explained of course and
Hickman's run because imagine it like i
can't imagine a story where heaven
doesn't explain everything you know at
the end and then like secret I guess
Silver Surfer will tie into it too but
that's one of the things that drove me
nuts is because right now like I mean
last days and I'm gonna do it like
chronologically you know I've already
got the secret war series going and so
yeah before I jump into anything any of
times after that you know it'll be last
days here's how all the characters are
ending in last days is still it won't
like as far as I know last days won't
officially wrap up into like light Knick
Knack next month of the month after
oh great like when all the issues are
done like all these overlap wait three
servers oh no that's right low-key ended
didn't he yeah yeah lucky ended last
week yeah ended with the destruction of
Oz garden okay yeah that's why you do
Loki's last days Loki and amendment with
though okay was that not an amazing
reveal like the the end of Loki's series
where cuz you see I like the reveal but
I didn't like the final issue cuz I
thought the final issue was very like
end of evangelion Lego is the true self
and it was it was amazing because what I
got out of it was at the end of the
series they were like that Ragnarok
remember that like that six issue
limited series Ragnarok did we put out
during you know then just simple that
wasn't Ragnarok like that was some stuff
happening like this is we can keep
having Ragnarok cycle you can never stop
yeah I loved it right up until the last
couple minutes from like oh you're doing
one of these endings though you're do it
you're doing one of these at least the
magneto book went out with a bang at
least Magneto's ending was like look if
the world's gonna die I'm gonna kill a
couple more fools before this all and
that's why like I'm thinking that what's
gonna happen is Jason Aaron here's
here's what I think is gonna happen
I think Loki and seeker wars is Loki
from the end of last days you were
saying from the Thor's book and that is
the same one because at the end of that
book he said I have the power to go
anywhere in the multiverse I want now I
could check in with Silver Surfer I
could check in with seek Wars or I could
just go to the future until all this
crap blows over yes yeah my thought is
like that is the Loki from the end of
last days and here's what I think is
gonna happen find out tomorrow cuz that
book comes out tomorrow I think that
what's gonna happen is Loki is gonna run
into Thor from the earth-616 continuity
yeah and there you know he seems like
you're the real low key like how did you
survive all that kind of stuff you know
and then Loki's are gonna say something
to the effect of like there was a true
Ragnarok what
it is and then Jason Aaron is gonna be
like BAM like in the Thor book and like
that's what Nick Fury said to Thor like
the cycle of Ragnarok never ends or
something like that or you never stop
Ragnar or something like that and then
cuz some of that the interesting that
was like a huge impact on Thor like
where he wasn't you like the Odin sleep
kind of thing yeah I'm liking this
theory well that's that was mine that
was the only wrench in it though is that
Aaron didn't write that Loki book though
so I wonder how much he's actually gonna
take from the Loki book to his own thing
no I'll just take the ending cuz cuz at
the ending like the once you said above
and shadows showed up and they were like
this is the end of everything like all
this is gone like this is everything's
curtains this is Ragnarok the whole nine
yards it was Loki leading a war against
Asgard like that miss your stories lucky
yeah like that was Ragnarok playing out
in that in that comic and the idea I
think that Jason Aaron is gonna like at
least what I would do anyway because I'd
rather get this I better get that cloud
out from over my head like I just say
well I'm around like last night ended
with Loki well that's what Nick Fury was
referring to he's like you know like
that you know it always ends or
something you something to that effect
something along the lines of you never
stop Ragnarok and that was that was kind
of my thought but unless like back on
the back on the whole thing that's
that's one thing that sort of Drew me
absolutely nuts so drew me off the wall
was that you know Marvel's doing things
in such a weird way you know and even
now I think they announced that with the
final book of secret Wars coming out
there that's coming out like after they
start the new universe yeah it's like
come on
Marvel that's yeah and that's that's
what kind of drives me nuts is because
you know with with DC I always felt like
they did it best when it came to
rebooting their continuity as they said
flashpoint everything gets folded in new
universe born
BAM number ones except for Green Lantern
in Batman and that was because they
always made a lot of money so they don't
restock and that was and that was it and
and literally like the flash like Mary
Ellen's gone like like there's like
Batman of the Green Lantern are the only
characters whose continuities you have
to worry about like no one else you
don't have to worry about continuities
from anyone else even the super
problematic stuff from the Morison run
that would contradict everything else
that's going up it's like nope keep
buying the Morrison trains
and that's that's the kicker's I mean
like if you like like reading Batman for
example you could say like well I mean
you know knife all still relevant it all
happened in a five-year window is still
relevant all happen in the five-year
window everything like demon everything
that from 1939 has under the Red Hood
all that stuff maybe died but no matter
what became the Red Hood
yeah you know of all the Robins were
still Robins in this five year window
when Lily bad at being Batman because he
had like five Robins and a five year
window one Robin a year and I'm not
gonna tell you that's like the most
action-packed five years oh my god
coming into existence like several
crises and my degree in Lantern going
crazy and tearing up the universe oh
yeah five years he is an active active
man that bad man yeah but that was that
was you know say what you want like at
the end of the day DC was smart way to
that Marvel I think needs to do the same
thing they need to come back and they
need to say okay multiverse like the
beyonders power goes out creates a new
universes everybody's minds get wiped
new universe you know new multiverse BAM
go from there and now character school
get to remember it just to make them
special oh yeah I mean oh man I would
like that too thing old man Logan
remember everything oh man Logan's
Silver Surfer and Loki how funny would
it be if they're like old man Logan's
trying to tell them stories like
fracking my day this event happened like
Oh silly ol and Logan with your crazy
and took over the world what are you
talking about man yeah one time the
whole x-men like having an argument with
like Jubilee or something like that like
I killed you so shut up and you please
look like I'm trying to take care of my
kid now do you mind right they still got
that kid that's stupid were you still a
vampire too
no cuz that kid's gonna throw up and be
set no axe and Sentinel X's cool I know
that like because what will be
interesting here's that here's a pitch
for Marvel it's like pitch away oh
here's a pitch the pitch is um you said
everything now right but like you still
kind of want to make everybody young
and and and have everybody had a shared
cut you what everybody be young so that
everybody can be relatable you want
everybody to have a shared continuity
because that's you're still doing that
and you also want to like update
everyone's origins so that no one fought
in the Korean War
okay set at eight months later put
everything out now but do something a
little bit like what they're doing with
the Spider Man The Wonder Years books
come by spikey yeah herp as I like to
call where it's basically like untold
tales of spider-man but teenage stories
of yeah but it's their way of kind of
showing of updating spider-man's origin
Ultima Singh if you will spider-man's
origin without without saying it out
loud and why don't you make that into
remember those remember those cool
graphic novels they put out a while ago
called chapter one I recently looked
those up were you talking about that
with you so they chapter one spider-man
yeah well no I actually that's something
totally different
chapter one spider bait is horrible they
were like John Byrne you know what
you're doing here three to spider-man's
origin and he's like okay and the fans
are like nope you do this and yeah you'd
read Superman to spider-man is like okay
everyone like everybody got their powers
from the same lab explosion also there's
a lab explosion now and because Sandman
and Norman Osborn have the same hair
styles they're not now and how about and
they're everyone's like what are you
doing so no I'm a John Byrne stop to be
really salty on the internet yeah yeah
I'll take some IU dolls create a tumblr
if you but I feel like the know I'm
talking with the season 1 graphic novels
yeah I remember
it's like Doctor Strange x-men
spider-man had one but you do that where
you and you call them season ones or
chapter ones whatever you want to do but
you put out everything now so it's all
happening now and you have a Bible for
each character and let's say you get
like the senior editors and they all
come up with like you know what happened
what didn't Blair and and they go and
they just they just they did they don't
even like write a whole current like
chronological this is what happens to
this they just write the events that
happened and the events that didn't or
they say all the events happened and all
those events are now
seasonal graphic novels made by really
really good creators that come out
periodically that fill in the gap
between the gap between the start up to
the new birth of time and where we are
eight months later so that you're like
oh come on yeah
like on this new in this new all-new
all-different marvel universe so you
could have your cake but eat it too so
you could you could literally tell like
maximum carnage again but in like an
original graphic novel done by Warren
Ellis or Nick Spencer and make it effing
amazing and if you and you could even
release both them at the same time you
know like here's original and you just
call it like you know maximum carnage
like you know whatever Marvel prime and
mark maximum carnage Season one or
whatever but you know you you know what
I'm not there marketer you they come up
with the names but but the point being
you know like demon in a bottle is that
a story sure who would write a really
bitching demon in the bottle it doesn't
invalidate the demon bottle that
happened before you just get to update
it now and make it have happened and
he'll like you could even work without
people and make like Secret Wars like
the old Secret Wars 84 like then tell a
new Secret Wars and but it's a graphic
novel made by like like one creative
team that works all the other creative
teams to make something interesting like
just a way to fill in the gaps without
messing with the current publications
and also not like rushing continuity
that you're not really quite sure about
anyway I felt always did a really good
job of what you're saying the cartoons
back in the day always a good job of
that oh yeah okay let's take a story
that like may have happened in the 40s
and the 50s but we'll update it for
modern time and we'll tell it now oh
yeah how do we how do we distill that
like I'm going like I'm going through it
like you know get like writing out
everything for the for the Phoenix saga
I'm what's really funny like really from
that you mention that were the cartoons
it's like I can guarantee you people who
were like people who saw x-men the
animated series like people are gonna
like this is just like the cartoon I'm
like yes it is yes yes oh my god that
cartoon they were literally like Phoenix
saga okay I make this this but
all the same stuff yeah okay and didn't
they do it like three episodes then they
do it like a really short amount of time
it was a season it was always a whole
city it was Ben it was the Phoenix
target and then the Dark Phoenix saga
yeah it was unforgivable yeah because
you would look like forgiveable it was
because you would randomly turn it on
right you'd be like okay time to watch
Fox kids click Phoenix saga part 7
you're damn it no it was it was good it
was 11 parts or some ridiculous number
it was always great if you were able to
watch all of them yeah if you could
catch them all but you never you never
caught them in the in sequence and they
always repeated the old like other ones
and some and when they went into
syndication you know it was never gonna
be like a cool self-contained episode
who's gonna be a friggin episode from
the Phoenix saga where nothing happens
and gene like looks sad like that's all
you get oh also you get Professor X and
Magneto walking through the savage I
remember that was great it was better
than their adaptation of like the 12
like yeah
no was it no maybe this wolf came out
yeah 12 came after that I think because
they they had an episode called Beyond
Good and Evil like a season Kotler full
episodes called Beyond Good and Evil
which is like Apocalypse getting all the
psychics and I thought my thought was
they did they pretty much did the exact
same thing with like like Beyond Good
and Evil is like the twelve basically
like - the scrolls and it was literally
just like cable like oh my god we need
to go you know all that kind of good
stuff
yeah yeah yeah nonetheless um I will say
this one of the funny things that I
always thought was kind of interesting
was if they are if they are gonna do
that if they are gonna produce original
graphic novels and there's something
going to say these are old stories that
are reprinted
then they need to do that because the
problem right now is like I said it's
kind of funny if you go and then read
like an original graphic novel like like
the infinity revelation perfect example
the Infinity revelation written by jim
Starlin alright it was it wasn't that
bad it was almost unreadable no you're
full of crap it was I thought it was it
was phantom some warlock entering each
other's minds yeah it sure was jim
Starlin there was nothing
not great it was not that bad at all it
was not that bad
see see people people look at Jim
something like he was a one-hit wonder
he had Infinity Gauntlet and everyone's
like oh my god Jim Jones greatest writer
the only event that has infinity on it
that I like is infinity go the reward
free crusade infinity itself although
infinity itself just the self-contained
book was cool
even though Thanos is like a cameo in it
yeah infinity just there was being like
think I'm gonna do something messed up
and then at the end heroes they just hit
him a bunch and then like his son is
like nope doesn't he fight another time
yeah it's like the fight to the fight
between Thanos and black bolts one of
the coolest moments yes in commerce
because he's like he's like tell me
where my son is in like black hole and
answer in my face he screams in his face
and he's like then just take it to the
grave one thing I want to see I want to
see that in infinity war like when
Marvel does their when they do those
movies I want to see like like I want
Black Bolt canonic brawl ends - yeah be
like built up you know and like you seem
using his powers and it's just like
laying waste of stuff and then Thanos
like somebody have is he asked him a
question and like Black Bolt screams in
his face but nonetheless like infinity
revelation is a good example like family
well where does this fit into continuity
it's like well it doesn't there's an
original graphic novel with good because
it's about Thanos and Adam warlock and
so no one's writing about those two like
no one's write about Adam warlock except
jim Starlin so whatever no don't worry
that though write about him when he gets
to be able to get a new solo series as
soon as he's back in the movie that's
how you're gonna know see that's that
that right there see people are like how
do we how are we gonna know if like Adam
warlock is gonna be in the movies when
he gets a solo series every book yeah
that's how you know he's gonna be in the
movie Adam warlock Adam warlock is like
Pucci when Adam warlock is not around
other characters need to ask where's
Adam warlock louder and more
in-your-face have access
you'll have spider-man like st. hath
like maybe we should call Adam warlock
people were asking me an episode of
Commons to coffee they were like so do
you think we're gonna see the real
Mandarin and I was I was like cuz I
asked him to clarify so you talk about
like this had been Kingsley comeback or
like the Mandarin Mandarin they were
like the Mandarin manner I was like nope
I don't like why I said because if you
were you would have seen him in an Iron
Man book right by now he's in a
shang-chi know yeah oh no I know I'm
just saying like he I was I was almost
gonna say he's not even on battle world
but he is in that one shang-chi book and
he's all oh no there's a there's a cool
Mandarin in like one of the battle were
like you know like like two stories and
one issue kind of thing and I stopped
reading the anthology no they're awful
but like there's one there's one where
Wolverines a private detective and
there's a matter of knives and that's
super cool they're never gonna do
anything with that no I read secret love
that one was kind of interesting that
was a throwback to old romance comics
they had like daredevil and Karen page
and they had like Robbie Reyes and
Kamala Khan cuz the writer ours had did
a piece of fan art that the internet
really loved so that he got to write a
story about it later no I thought really
nice not read those anthology things
when Wolverine shows up to to doom I
guess and then like doom possesses him
or something the punisher ghost was sure
those are awesome no that was the
coolest one no I didn't I thought it was
just coming with dr. Punisher yeah yeah
yeah no that's awesome dr. Kassel MD but
be infertile for he was chased by the
infernal for dr. Kassel has whatever
ails your problems ladies like forty
five in the morning actually went to the
doctor today actual doctor Punisher
there's also what was it called
K
- Kate bishop from like 16 that's
important because her character there
gets plucked over to see you she goes to
the wall so that's cool and she's fun
Kate of Bishop if you will I like that I
I liked Kate bishop in Hawkeye I was sad
that they haven't really done anything
with her there was that book had to come
to an end to get rebooted again and you
had to wait like a year for friggin the
main Hawkeye book to be done yeah
understand I was like oh they're gonna
have these series continued to run even
after sigil Wars like once a good world
is coming to an end like with last days
some are some why are we getting new
characters yeah like should we be like
wrapping things up and not introducing
new care it's like it's like it's like
going to the grocery store like five
minutes for closes like now's a good
time to go buy groceries they know to be
leaving the store not going and buying
missed the boat well I see more like
buying merchandise in a con on the last
day they don't want to carry it out so
you can't we just get what you wanted to
see though by the way tip for the tip
for the chance for you ever one I buy
something in a con wait until like the
last 10 minutes because they do not want
to schlep into the car when I carry that
stuff it will be it and don't insult
them but like you could go like 50%
lower than what they're asking be like
hey man hey hey depends if it's like a
$500 thing and they'll knock a hundred
bucks off yeah I really need that Batman
bust Bank IRA Superman is really lonely
on my shelf he needs a friend I will say
I was that I was a toy con Isis all that
I was jealous we don't get those around
here where I'm amazing well our toy Con
video comes out tomorrow but there was a
dude who selling a Red Hulk statue the
hun was the size bike tour so he's
amazing they were asking 400 which i
think is not bad but at the end of the
week or at the end of the two days I
have a feeling you probably would have
gone down there like three to fifty
maybe if you can see didn't want to
carry that heavy ass thing that car but
I did not have that kind of I'm not like
I'm you know no hey I have no frigging
room for him and B I have no friggin
account like Bank Africa you didn't have
Red Hulk dollar
one day we'll be able to make Red Hulk
money ah that's movie nights yeah like I
don't feel bad with you know for like
hanging with you all because 50% of
something is better than a hundred
percent of nothing yeah if you have the
room and they can the end the funds you
shouldn't be like spending money on
things you don't got like you know if
you have no money don't be spending it
somewhere I could just hear Benny being
like oh really you guys buy her stuff
they send me stuff yeah oh great look
you know what guys like I have a really
good idea let's build a rocket ship and
go into space I've been working on that
for the last month we should actually we
should just start throwing things out
there like man you know it's great like
I don't know I'm trying think of some
kind of product from comics that we like
or just think some things we need like
man my my graphics card could do better
I love those radians though they're
pretty great but we got to be like Rick
from Rick and Morty and be like it'd be
like hey Nintendo Nintendo Wii sure send
me for the semi free things in the end
oh look you know what man I think would
be really all about Book Depository if
you want good trades book depositories
where it's that it depends on what they
said me exactly you'll never know until
you try
I still make Luke rate videos for
something it's no God Luke Rayman I got
one offer from tgn to make a loot crate
video and like I was like I mean yeah
sure I'll give it a shot like they send
me to loot crate and I was like this
crates garbage and so like I made a
video and I was like yeah I mean there's
some stuff it was like the most
unexcited loot crate video ever they
were it's like two bad ones to everyone
good one yeah and like I had to send it
back to two tgn so they could send it to
loot crate and make sure it was okay and
and I was and they were like no we're
like loot crate shows not to and I was
like well that's fine because that was
garbage I'm gonna tell my fans of my
crappy stuff like no way yes
it sucks great being in Canada any of
those box services I would get instantly
cost me $15 more for shipping and
handling yeah
oh yeah I got loot I got a the club
Marvel's collector core is actually kind
of cool yeah I want that but 15 extra
box I like you but I don't 15 extra box
like this unless they sent it to me for
free in which case that will tell
everyone how great it is and how they
need to buy it I have heard of comic
crate though I have yet to check them
out but I do have to I do and I'm a male
small waist brain and people who really
want us to do stuff I'm just like I've
just been like oh just so you get the
name raise that comic crate or comic
bento cuz comic bento is a whole there's
one that's great this one that's bent
okay cuz i know cuz i know our mean does
some good stuff with bent when i think
sammy does some good stuff with bento to
actually nice I don't know they had a I
don't know what I don't even know comic
pretty existed yeah I'm gonna be
googling them right now I'm gonna be
saying they have a mine service yeah
alright guys we're gonna wrap this up I
think sounds gotta bounce out of here in
the next few minutes and yeah yeah like
we've all got a ton of videos to work on
so um yeah was already run this week
everybody have coming up great question
I got you you a person so let's hear it
I got I got epic panel history coming
down the line people really seem to be
liking that show it's one of the few
shows I've actually able to turn out
myself on like an actual weekly basis
you know I basically just take a funny
panel this week I'm doing the famous a
bat slap thing where he slaps Robin sure
everybody's seen the bit yeah my parents
are Jared but I know deep I go deep in
the history of it and you might be
surprised what I actually find on this
when I shocked myself and educated
myself actually on this one I've done
that before where you look like and
really yeah if you head on over to the
weekly full right now actually I think
there's a video up from me I started
doing these where are they now and I did
one on where like the actors from the
original Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
and
meant to do that along I meant to do
that one a long time to go and like that
suppose a news broke out of like oh
here's the character breakdown for what
they're gonna be in the 2017 movie so I
finally kicked myself in the ass to
finish it and people really seemed to
like it so it looks like I'm gonna be
doing a volume 2 soon where I talk about
all the supporting actors and where they
ended up yeah that's so that's what I'm
up to
sweet I'm shooting back issues tonight
so it'll be route by Thursday we're
doing a epic daredevil event I guess
from you know from from the bygone era
there's a lot of there's a lot of
Twitter activity about like what event
I'm doing no I thought shadow yeah you
did you did it was not shadow land but
it I think that when because no one had
on Twitter's guessed it yet when it
comes out that can be like right yeah
yeah it's awful it is so bad and it's as
bad as I remember it being when I read
it back in the day it's one of those
back in the day ones I picked it up and
I was like oh my god and it's because
the the artist on the book was doing a
signing at like a comic store at the
mall and my Peter is like you like these
let's take you to the mall and you'll
talk to this artist that you've never
heard of and you'll ask him how to get
into the comic industry mr. Simonds I'm
10 my parents don't this is this is
gonna be a pattern for my family by the
way is that they're gonna be like oh let
me take an unrealistic thing that don't
really understand or grasp and then
encourage you to go do it these are the
same people who are like can you not
find a job well have you've gone to the
office that you applied to and asked
them to I asked just to talk to them I'm
like III I would be thrown out I would
be they would call security on me like
our parents are very similar by the
sounds oh yeah no they're well that's
because they're you know they're in
their 50s 60s or 70s like they're you're
they're older folk and they they have a
completely like my dad hasn't looked for
a job in his life like that's because he
said he works for himself like he's well
yeah he owns own business like he's
literally never had a boss and he thinks
that
that he knows how to tell me how to like
look I'm like you gotta be crazy you
have no frickin idea you had no idea 30
years ago and you think you got
something out like no the end this of
course these are generation these are
what are we
Millennials our generation wires I
forget what we fought I think I'm a
little younger than you guys so I think
I skew a little better although I've
always considered myself part of
Generation X is my I think yeah I think
we're technically part of Generation X
even though that really that really is
like if you were in high school in 1993
than you then you're a generation Xer I
was not but I think we still count
because we're part of that echo yeah
yeah yeah we're yeah we're part of like
yeah earth-2 Generation X guys some guy
was giving me a hard time in the chat
yeah man cope and he was like who are
the other two guys also the first ones
called ban the second ones called hammer
there are a lot of people were like
where's Benny every [ __ ] ten minutes
it's Ben where's Benny I'm like yeah
here man I'm sorry's in France and on a
European vacation we haven't asked him I
think it's at comics Dorian for you he
puts a picture on Facebook the other day
you can follow my Instagram but don't do
that comic story no no no what you
should be looking for is comic pop what
that is a great channel you should check
out every time I get away from when
Benny comes back like hey what you guys
do well we work out how we basically
just ran you down and shield a lot yeah
it was great yeah it's not very much
unlike what we do normally yeah anyway
Rob what are you working on me I have
the Phoenix saga coming out and then
death of the family and then I think I
would have thought explain these two
Dragon Ball Z characters so like the
history of Frieza
which is gonna be fun because okay see
see I tell people about the cz people
mm-hmm
man Dragon Ball like resurrection of f
have some very important information
with regards to freezes in it now - okay
you watch Dragon Ball Z back in the day
right oh yeah of course the hell freezes
just like showed up and had a ton of
power and nobody ever knew how we got it
yeah okay we'll drag or like we're a
resurrection of ever explains that
interesting cuz we know he's part of a
family yet you would assume that his dad
and brother would be stronger than him
and yet they seem to go back and forth
on that also depending on what dub
you're watching they say he's a gangster
where's like he's in the planet trade
he's a gangster but then it's like no he
looks to be like a serious warlord he
looks that like more in common with
friggin apocalypse or Mongol than he
does like Jabba the Hutt if ya know in
the movie he's like whoa like like me
and my family members are like mutant
among like Musa Moana races like we were
just born within less same amount of
power and like we're just like that and
so which is like okay cool and therefore
mayor it'll just be like here's
everything that happened over the course
of the ship interesting absolutely dies
yeah like it's really cool like Frieza
was always my favorite Dragon Ball
filament or Dragon Ball Z behind yeah I
know that sounds like all but cuz he was
the first one no cuz he was like
actually was the one with the most
connection yeah he had so the character
like he has so much character to him but
but yeah so that's not just coming
though is a video huh know what now I
said I didn't watch the show oh god you
missed out man I saw the first season
which is like a thousand episodes I
loved for this generation they had to
make Dragon Ball Z Kai which is based
like we recut the show and took out all
the filler trem like all you kids today
man yeah you don't know what it was like
back in the day it was like it like man
you don't know what it was like like
when Goku once we were saying - and then
three episodes later or he goes super
saiyan like three episodes him and
Frieza first time fighting like you
weren't there man
that was our Vietnam is our Vietnam man
like 70 70 episodes to span like a three
or five minute fight yep yeah that was I
did get to see or you know you could
just go watch Dragon Ball Z abridged
which is yeah where it's yeah yeah it is
a good show and it probably keeps more
of the plot than any other
Brij series weather like no just the
events as they happen are funny on there
oh yeah but remember blue I remember it
blew me away for Dragonball when I found
out that all the names are actually
Japanese puns I'm like seriously yeah
they're all but they're all vegetable
jokes yep
yes I do remember that the [ __ ] you take
super seriously is all one giant joke in
its own country it's weird man it's
weird anyway guys we're gonna wrap this
up a soda up it's a pretty fun episode
ranting about comics and so on so uh
yeah I guess we'll catch everybody later